As Black History Month kicks off this week,
we have a fantastic story from The Philadelphia Tribune.
The charcoal company, Kingsford,
is celebrating Black barbecue culture in America
with a new fellowship program called Preserve the Pit.
Take a look.
So as we stoke the embers of barbecue history,
we invite the next generation of entrepreneurs to blaze
their own trail, because it's only by investing
in the future that we'll preserve the past.
Okay, now here to tell us about the barbecue genius
behind Bludso's Barbecue, the Compton Barbecue stand
that's gone worldwide, please welcome a fifth generation
pit master who learned to barbecue from his great-aunt.
It's Chef Kevin Bludso.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Kevin.
What's up, ya'll?
How ya'll doin'?
Wow.
What's up, Drew?
What's up, Ross?
I'm really
honored to meet you.
I've been to your LA Outpost, and it is just, I mean,
there's a reason that you've franchised
and become such a huge deal, Kevin.
Thank you for stopping by.
The pleasure's all mine.
I'm elated to meet you and Ross.
I'm lookin' forward to this.
Let's have some fun today.
(audience laughs)
We are so honored to be speaking with you.
And also, you are a mentor
in this new incredible fellowship program.
Will you please tell us about Preserve the Pit.
Oh wow, Preserve the Pit by Kingsford,
is the prime example of somebody keepin' it 100
and puttin' their money where their mouth is.
I mean, the biggest problem a lot of times when you
start a business, is the not knowin' the know-how,
and havin' all the information.
So many restaurants fail.
Kingsford is puttin' a stop to all that.
I mean they have some legendary, and not talkin'
about myself, some legendary, up and coming,
young pit masters.
I mean, I tell people right now, go to Preserve the Pit
right now and sign up.
You got until now until March first and startin' in April,
we gonna get this thing goin' and we gonna have these people
locked in from April to September to teach them everything.
And Drew, you know where it's at and you got
some neighborhood in you.
You know, game is to be sold and not told.
And we givin' it up.
Kingsford and us is givin' it up.
Kingsford been puttin' good smoke in the air
for a long, long time, and now they are really
payin' it forward in what they're doin'.
I am so proud to be part of it.
It's just crazy.
What an incredible way to learn.
Yeah, and everybody, I mean loves barbecue.
We've been eatin' barbecue around here.
Yeah.
But barbecue's in your bones, Kevin.
(Drew laughs)
Now you say
you learned everything from your great-aunt.
Her name, Willie Mae Fields, right, you call Granny?
Yes, Miss Granny.
Yes, Miss Willie Mae Fields, Corsicana, Texas.
And my mom, learned a lot from my mom, Jane Bludso.
She'd have a fit if I kick her out of it.
You know, I'm born and raised in Compton,
so I had the best of both worlds.
You know, I grew up, like I said, I had the tough streets
of Compton and the country roads of Texas.
I learned both sides and I got to work
with her every summer.
She had this little hole in the wall, underground jute joint
that had a whole lotta things goin' on,
but always turnin' to the Karate Kid, wax on, wax off.
She was teachin' me things that I never thought I would use
in my life, that I still use to this day, man.
'Cause that was what she would always say,
boy, you oughta get you a legal hustle.
You know what I mean, legal hustle means learn how
to do something because you never know when time's gonna
get hard, you gonna lose a job, or somethin' like that
and you need somethin' legal to fall back on.
And who woulda known years later, you know, I would be
doin' Bludso's with the things that she taught me.
And that's what this program is about.
If I didn't have people like her in my life and teachin' me,
and now Kingsford and Preserve the Pit is givin' me
the opportunity to give it back to some people
who really, really need it, man.
It's amazin' and I am so glad to be part of this,
and some young and upcomin' legends on this team with us.
It's gonna be incredible, man.
I'm really lookin' forward to it.
I love your food so much.
I was so excited to do this with you.
Thank you from me and Ross, really,
for sharing this really important information.
And for pit masters at home who wanna apply
for the Preserve the Pit fellowship, you have until
March first, and we'll share the details on our website
at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, I had a good time.
(audience applauds)
Great to meet you.
No problem.
And see you soon.
See you soon.
We wanna leave you with something that you can take
on the road with you.
It's time for Doggy Bag.
(dog barks)
Well, it's the perfect accompaniment to, not only Meat Week,
any food situation.
This is my go-to.
It's Solluna, is the brand.
It's Kimberly Snyder who is a true guru on health
and wellness and digestion,
and this is the feel-good digestive enzymes.
And you take them right before a meal and they help your
body metabolize proteins, fats, and carbs more effectively.
I never go anywhere without it.
It is my Amex card, and I notice a huge difference
in my weight gain if I don't take it.
For reals?
For reals.
I'll take two.
Yep, there ya go.
I take three before every meal.
Well, thank you, Drew, for these, I'm obsessed.
And thank you all for watching.
We hope we get to see you again tomorrow.
We hope you have a wonderful day.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)